va craquer oracle ou des bonbons ou va
tout de suite joué avec rohff
on va jouer art of boyard d'accord of
boyard vous allez affronter deux
chroniqueurs et chimène badi dans trois
épreuves de fort boyard
alors attention ce sont des poids de 2
kg il faut rester comme ceci donc plus
longue de 6 kg pas de 6 kg c'est vrai
faut rester le plus longtemps prostré
assez longtemps c'est le plus longtemps
possible bras tendus rolala j'ai regardé
le grès le plus longtemps possible
ces parcs ou [ __ ] adore ça a l'air
hyper lourd
j'adore
bon ça la salle mathieu et pierre
mathieu souffre déjà pierre urgent mme
harasym aurore d'hackett les gars je
maîtrise
[Musique]
un mot aussi va craquer oracle ou des
bonbons il va craquer aller
trans piranhas
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lemoine jean luc lemoine face à
sarov encore rohff en fait on lui fait
tout faire alors attention chacun votre
tour vous allez taper sur le clou avec
un celui qui termine par enfoncer le
clou tout bien sûr de toi celui qui
termine par enfoncer le clou à gagner
entre fort
voilà aulas
les gars jouent sans bricoleurs en tout
cas où
aux tensions dans la tronche mais
jean-luc voilà il est minuit et demi on
essaie toujours attentionné mais à
droite l'autre fait l'autre fait l'autre
mais c'est joli mais c'est pas un jeu
mais non t'es pas droit voilà est allé
un mail idéaux perdu là non pas les deux
mais ces gens ne vont pas que oui oui
ce jour-là à peu
donnez-moi abandonné mois de [ __ ] de
marteau c'est intense en voilà prof
mes toiles à mon chéri je redresse mais
c'est pas possible que ces belles
séquences voilà c'est rohff qui a gagné
mais sans doute quelques bricoleurs
avola là bas tout est de planter
j'ai jamais vu un gars ça donnera
laissez tomber la dernière épreuve je la
sens pas du tout les laisser tomber
je suis allé faire fort boyard jean-luc
3 wii web on n'y allait pas un si je
peux vous donner un conseil qu'il faut
pas faire cette épreuve
[Musique]